i once went to gory where stalin was
born
have you been no yes
i was ages after the georgia war
and i went to enter the no man's land in
south ossetia and
kazia and
i said
i really gotta go to gory also here
because the shell had landed in gory
rather weirdly from the russian side and
gory is where son was born
and of course court is in georgia
and uh um let me have the museum of
stalin's birthplace they've been trying
to change for some years because it had
been
unadulteratedly pro-stalin for years
and the georgian authority this is in uh
um
uh his time were trying to make it into
a museum of stalinism
and it was really tough
the only place i've seen which is
similar is the house in mexico city
where trotsky was killed
uh that also is like they're not quite
sure what to do they
they don't want to say he's a bad guy
because they think that people won't
come anywhere um
stalin's house and gory had changed from
the museum of stalin to museum of
salonism there was this
large georgian woman with a pink pencil
who just had clearly been doing the tour
for like 50 years
and just pointed all the fastness you
did that classic thing i've also saw it
once in north korea where they they're
sort of that sort of communist thing
where they say here is this is 147 feet
high by 13 feet deep it like gives you
lots of fashion i don't care okay why
does it matter um they always give you
facts yeah
this is stalin's suitcase it is uh 13
inches wide by you know it isn't
anyhow and this woman did all of this
and it was all just wildly pro well not
pro signs just to explain the science
lives it was a great local boy done good
uh they didn't mention the fact he
killed more georges pagar than anyone
else
and we get get to the end and before
being taken to the gift shop where they
sell red wine with stalin's face on it
and among other things
and a lighter for this styling on it
uh
they uh they took you to a little room
under the stairs and they said this is a
replica of interrogation cell to show uh
uh represent horror of what happened in
stalin time uh now a gift shop as i said
there's no
no because i took the woman's side
the end i discovered she'd said this to
other journalists and visited before i
took it and said i said what do you
think about comrade stalin
and she said um let's say she'd
obviously done this
during communist times
she said it's
not my
place to judge you know sort of thing
which is an interesting comment in
itself i said yeah but he killed more
georgians and everyone you know and all
that sort of thing
and she it's not my place to judge or to
give my views and that sort of thing and
the franchise ever what do you feel
about it and she said um
it was like a hurricane
it happened
[Music]
that's interesting because uh if i may
mention clubhouse once again
i gotten a chance to talk to a few
people from mongolia
there's a woman from mongolia and they
talked about the fact that they deeply
admire stalin love she she sounded if i
may hopefully that's not crossing line i
think i'm representing her correctly and
saying
she admired him almost like
um
like loved them like the way people love
like a uh like a like jesus like a holy
figure well isn't that still the case in
large parts of russia yeah i mean he
keeps stalin keeps on winning greatest
russian of all time
and and that's perhaps maybe there's a
dip but if we were to think about the
long arc of history perhaps that's going
to go up and up and up and up as yeah
there's something about human memory
that it just you forget the details of
the atrocities of the past and remember
that i mean think of the number of
people we talk about as historical
heroes napoleon yeah i mean
british people don't talk about opponent
as a hero but the french
yeah
exactly
now you're no you didn't think that does
the else now again tricky ground but
everybody like the the the french
enormously my napoleon and they had many
animal aspects who was also
unbelievable brute and um killed many
people unnecessarily
and um there are lots of figures from
history that we sort of cover that over
with
you